don't forget last week biden accusing
the federal law enforcement of quote
egregious
tactics our law enforcement said they
were responsible for attacking
peaceful protesters that's not at all
what happened
jerry nadler you might have outdone the
ever confused biden gone a step further
calling violence in places like portland
the myth
everything we've been showing you don't
believe your own eyes believe this
psycho
there's violence across the whole
country do you just about the violence
from antifa
that's happening in portland right now
that's right that's that's a myth
that's being spread only in washington
d.c about antifa and portland
yes sir there's there's videos
everywhere online there's fires and
riots they're
throwing fireworks at uh federal
officers dhs is there
look online it gets crazy mr nadler
okay we got the congenital liar shift
and nadler
two of the biggest liars there's telling
you none of this is real that's a lie
is he that delusional that much in
denial that much disconnected from
reality
uh no i think it's all about an election